Here we have an example of players
paying real money for in game currency.
$0.99 cents will get you 3000 of gold,
$4.99 gets you 18, 000, and
so on, and you can see this bonus listed
underneath the higher priced items.
And this is a great example
of being clear about value.
The bonus markers make it obvious
that there's a specific benefit for
buying different,
higher priced items in the store.
And the user doesn't
have to do any math.
For example, I already know that
the $4.99 option compared to the $0.99
one will give me 20% more gold than
I would have gotten, had I gone for
the cheaper option.
The store layout is also very clear.
They're only selling one item,
gold, the in game currency.
So, the store isn't crowded
with too many options.
Let's look at another example of
a store that could be improved.
It has a good layout, but
I'm not immediately sure why I
should buy a higher priced item and
the store is mixing in game currency and
items for sale?
There's too much variety.
This example is not as clear as our last
one, and I would be less likely to buy
higher priced items, or
really, anything in this store.
So make sure to show what kind of value
a player will be getting by buying your
in-app items.
It's important to have a nice layout,
and
most importantly be clear about value.